from valdez taking the hill for the
astros today and if you're going to play
good defense you want to play behind
this guy he is a high ground ball
percentage type guy we will talk about
that throughout the course of the game
but on the season in 15 starts has a
beautiful 3-1-6 era trying to improve
upon that during the course of this game
last time out against kansas city
battled through six and two thirds
innings you know dusty baker would love
to have him have another extended outing
getting into that seventh inning
ground ball right side right to jose
altuve two big hops and this game starts
with a four to three
and
this ball on the ground again and correa
with that bright orange sleeve shows off
the arm
on a ground ball to his left is he cut
in front of jose altuve for the second
out he doesn't have to throw too many
pitches
let the hitters make mistakes which they
just did
correa busy again up the middle makes
the play three groundouts to start this
one proper valdez knows what the theme
is today
tyler anderson has really pitched well
for the mariners overall this year 22
starts with six and eight record era at
4-1 125 innings he has 101 strikeouts
over 27 walks typically he throws a lot
of strikes that would be a key to stay
away from the walks this afternoon
fastball top of the zone
dylan moore settling under
[Applause]
right to see
easy play to that
still more
get some action here early on nice
inning by tyler anderson valdez working
quickly here down to the count to toro
three and one chopper hustling in as
diaz making the throw on the move in
time to get abraham torro
how much they take it seriously
uh there is a reason why they're so good
and it's something that the first time i
ever saw and how they come together
after the infield and they all give each
other dap and nice job and all that and
they're sweating and all that i was like
wow two one
ground ball right side to his right
altuve second baseman has it throws to
first in time to in the inning so a
couple of two out base runners but
that's all and after one and a half
astros nothing mariners nothing euron
alvarez stands in 24 homers tied for six
in the league with 84 driven in and
alvarez hits the first pitch deep to
right center going back on it is haniker
looking up see you later
into the astros bullpen for euron
alvarez's 25th of the year one-nothing
astros
the astros being aggressive early on our
md anderson strike zone guess what 89
inner third and up that's not enough to
beat jordan
as uriel goes to third and it brings up
taylor jones a designated hitter jones
had himself a day yesterday drove in
four runs going three for five another
three two
and that's a bouncing ball third base
side and under the glove of seeger who
tried to backhand it kicks off the side
wall and in the short left field scoring
as guriel jones goes to second
and it is two to nothing astros very
costly mistake by sager i don't know if
that'll go as an error or not
all right bummy here's your infield
defense what you got for me
he got in between
he had a decision to make do i try and
make the player do i knock it down he
got in between you can see kyle seeger
the veteran shaking his head
yeah so he took one step back and then
said oh no i got to come in to get it
by the time he made that choice it was
way too late
here's carlos correa flight out to left
his first time up
that ball rocketed into center field
that'll be down for a hit altuve
aggressively turns second kelnick drops
the ball so correa is going to get into
second base
a little miscue out there in center
field altuve going first to third but
then correa gets the extra 90 feet
anderson battling here where the base is
loaded 0-2 pitch
got him good pitch cutter's been very
effective for him at the right times
as he leaves the bases loaded two
nothing houston
that's a good pitch that's been a good
one for him that's been a money pitch
cut her in
here's the pitch on the way fastball
swing and a miss for strike three
another strikeout for anderson
back-to-back strikeouts for tyler
seeger
it's going to be murph going to be
secret
good ending by
tyler anderson 1-1
lifted in the center myers coming in
still coming in and makes the catch on
the jog
ground ball short hop pick by oled miss
diaz
good that's a nice play for route number
two
there you go
valdez with a one two three sixth inning
he is through six two hits allowed
astros leading two to nothing
joe smith and harrison jam here he's got
diaz at third myers in second is o2
swing at a miss as a fastball comes
running in on him and he swings right
through it jones is disposed of on three
pitches
two outs astros threatening two in
scoring position the pitch
swinging at a miss a fastball at the
knees maldonado cuts through it and joe
smith hot knife through butter barely
breaks his sweat strikes out jones and
maldonado to end the astros threat in
the sixth inning
warming up here that little punch shot
that's to be a double play caught by
yuli and a double play no chance for
abraham toro on the line drive by
terence
robert valdez through seven innings he
is rolling along with a three-hit
shutout
and nice dig by ty france
double play to the eighth inning we go
to nothing music needed to get a base
runner and there it is back to the top
of the lineup in crawford
jp put a good swing on it drives it
center field one hop two hops off the
fence
bowers has scored
jp crawford a two-out rbi double got a
ball game at 2-1 against former mariner
kendall braveman good time france 3-4-5
coming up here for the mariners in the
ninth
hottest hitters in baseball give it a
ride left center field and deep and it's
gone we get a tie ball game
tied france ringing the bell again
2-2 game in the ninth in houston
[Applause]
so that puts runners on second and third
with two outs and j.p crawford
to bat here
got him
brooks rally is fired up as we've ever
seen him
tips his cap to the crowd
first right on right base is loaded
nobody out bottom of the 10th inning
tied at two here is correa
strike three call bro oh baby
pitch to castro swaying and a miss
struck him out two down
three two from seawalled one more time
nigeria struck him out paul seawall
coming up huge
he gets the mariners out of a bases
loaded 10th inning jam
and the mariners have runners on at
first and third with nobody out here in
the top of any number eleven two two
get the other way base hit
fairness have the lead base hit tied
france jp scores
hannigan will hold it second
here is kyle seeger runners on it first
and second with nobody out
high flag ball deep center field better
than the gap it's gone
a three-run homer by kyle seeger six two
lead mariners
kaboom
jake myers two for four today first
pitch and myers lines this in the right
field that's a base hit
guriel can walk home and jake myers with
its third hit of the game it is six to
three seattle bases loaded altuve at the
plate mariners by three in the two two
pitch swung on and this struck him out
outfielders playing deep
big pitch here two and one
live ball center field jk coming on
that's your ball game
how about the mariners bouncing back
after those two blowouts beautiful game
they win it in extra innings six to
three and johann ramirez the biggest
moment in his big league career